on May 3rd this adaptation of a 1980s TV
show arrives starring Ryan Gosling as a
stuntman who tasked with finding a
missing movie star he Stars opposite
Emily Blunt who plays the director on
the film he's working for as well as a
former flame it's a will they won't they
Vibe with huge effects and action
sequences and Gosling looks like he's
bringing his usual amount of Charisma
self-deprecating humor and overall
handsomeness 2 weeks later on May 17th
if you're looking to cleanse your pallet
with a fun half animated rump you'll
definitely want to head to the theaters
for if starring Ryan Reynolds it posits
a world where ifs AKA imaginary friends
are real and Ryan's if voiced by the
ever hilarious Steve Carell is now back
in his life Reynolds and a young girl
played by Kaylee Fleming have to pair up
all the abandoned imaginary friends with
new kids the trailer looks like a lot of
fun and who doesn't love the dry WID of
Sir Deadpool himself